la crise du nouveau coronavirus pousse
la chaîn à construire un hôpital en un
temps record 6 jours si tout le temps
qu'il faudra pour construire un nouvel
hôpital à one la ville de onze millions
d'habitants qui est l'épicentre de cette
crise
les autorités n'ont pas débattu
longuement sur le projet quelques heures
à peine après la décision la machinerie
s'activaient déjà 35 pelle mécanique une
dizaines de bulldozers s'affairent à
préparer site où sera construit
l'hôpital de 25 mille mètres carrés et
d'une capacité de 1000 patients les
travailleurs utiliseront des murs
préfabriqués pour accélérer le travail
et réduire les coûts
une fois l'hôpital construit il faudra
trois jours pour l'équipe et en matériel
médical et ouvrira ses portes le 3
février la chaîne avait réalisé un
exploit similaire lors de la crise du
sras ce en construisant un hôpital en
une semaine
[Musique]